[Music]
which batman do people keep referencing
in peacemaker and how could it tie into
the upcoming flash movie are these just
jokes or are they actually hidden
secrets that only the cleverest fans
could find
christopher smith is living proof that a
sucker is born every minute on the
internet throughout the first season of
peacemaker he reveals that aquaman is
mercurious and superman loves to leap
the tallest buildings for a chance to
snack on fresh butt burritos of course
these are only a handful of fun facts
about the justice league that he scoured
the internet for and he treats every
dubious comment section as gospel
you actually believe that
he has an insane story for every single
superhero
the question is how far do his
conspiracy theories reach it doesn't
help that he came from a home where his
father was a racist and misogynist
criminal who bought into every crackpot
that monetizes the spread of
misinformation and division while the
rest of project butterfly has poked
holes in his supposed facts about the
world peacemaker still holds on to an
outrageous belief system that would make
the average person question their sanity
the other somewhat unlikely possibility
is that these are in fact real facts in
the world of peacemaker
i'm so
sick of that rumor
[Music]
it's
not a rumor
while it's common to include easter eggs
and comic book references in superhero
shows john economos's declaration to
peacemaker has an interesting
implication
i'd rather be with
batmite than you who's batman the two
foot tall interdimensional imp who
stands batman i'd rather be with him
it all but confirms the existence of
batmite in the dceu fans have seen this
pesky character appear in other tv shows
such as the new adventures of batman and
batman the brave and the bold but this
is the first time he's been mentioned in
a live-action show on his official
instagram account james gunn confirmed
that batmite is now canon but is he
really if he's not actually seen how can
anyone actually be sure he exists we'd
better stop here before the
philosophical implications get
overwhelming
it was a brave decision to turn auggie
smith into the white dragon of the dc eu
in the context of the story and our
understanding of peacemaker's troubled
past it was a natural fit to turn augie
into the white supremacist super villain
who led his son astray with a highly
questionable upbringing that said there
have been multiple versions of the white
dragon in the comics so even though
auggie might be dead in peacemaker he
has a legion of followers who are more
than likely to take up the mantle in the
future
ask peacemaker who his best friend is
and there's only one answer eagerly to
be fair who wouldn't want to be bffs
with an eagle that's capable of gouging
out the eyes of enemies with both its
beak and talent be that as it may
vigilante might have something to say
about this current friendship hierarchy
vigilante just like an all-time classic
run with my best friend my second best
friend eagley my fifth best friend out
of bio there's no doubt in anyone's mind
that vigilante looks up to peacemaker
and sees him as his only friend even
though peacemaker won't freely admit it
in the public he does view adrian chase
as a friend albeit a bit of an annoying
one that said vigilante has been there
for him when he's needed him the most he
might not be the most conventional of
friends or a rational human being but he
hasn't let down peacemaker yet
maybe just maybe vigilante may finally
be acknowledged as peacemaker's best
friend one day
well probably not
don't tell v but
after eagley
or my bff
[Music]
where exactly does peacemaker fit in the
dc film universe's timeline judging by
the events and characters it takes place
immediately after the suicide squad
which is considered a part of the dc eu
in this timeline the batman is still ben
affleck's version of the caped crusader
however this doesn't quite align with
something that auggie's neighbor says to
peacemaker about the dark knight not
killing
batman doesn't kill people because he's
a [ __ ] he's a dark creature of the
night he's a jackass recalling the
events of batman vs superman dawn of
justice batman didn't straight up murder
criminals but he didn't exactly pump the
brakes on the batmobile to avoid
crashing into them nor did he exercise
much restraint in the brutal beatdowns
he dished out either
it sure looks like he kills at least a
couple of bad guys
one possibility here is that peacemaker
might actually take place after the
flash movie the upcoming movie will
feature barry allen breaking the
timeline and crossing the streams of the
multiverse so in the process he could
have brought in a new batman who has
much cleaner hands than batblack
alternatively we're reading too much
into what's most likely just a joke
make no mistake about it christopher
smith is a love machine he's got all his
love to give and all his life to live
however there's a revealing moment in
the episode mirn after reading that
indicates a midnight rendezvous that
didn't quite finish as expected
as a favor to jamil the janitor from the
hospital where smith was peacemaker
speaks to the local school in an effort
to make jamil's child seem more popular
naturally the children ask him a lot of
questions though there's one specific
query that sticks out more than the
others a little girl holds up her hand
and asks peacemaker if he remembers her
mom becky coolidge
i haven't seen her in like 10 years
i think you might be my real dad what
it's played like a joke but it could be
an interesting plot thread for a future
storyline what if the little girl really
is peacemaker's daughter and what if her
mother is someone who could be linked to
another superhero or villain
in the episode stop dragging my heart
around it's implied that peacemaker
sexuality is a bit more fluid than his
general demeanor might have implied
series creator james gunn himself
revealed to empire magazine that john
cena played a pivotal role in shaping
the character's sexuality gunn said
john does improv all the time and he
just turned christopher smith into this
hyper-sexualized dude that is open to
anything sexually
considering peacemaker's openness to
romantic partners there's a chance that
he and vigilante could develop into
something more in the future as well the
two of them share an intimate encounter
with amber so it isn't like they haven't
had a close encounter of the bedroom
kind at the same time it could go a long
way to explaining vigilante's borderline
obsession with smith what started off as
a bond over violent crime fighting could
blossom into something more special and
intimate between them that said the
answer to this question is probably not
since peacemaker ends with an implied
bond between chris and harcourt
peacemaker
what a joke
rick flags line from the suicide squad
has haunted smith ever since he killed
task force x's leader while he might
have thought he had a very good reason
for doing so at the time it still
doesn't help ease his conscience
ultimately he was simply following
orders which is something that amanda
waller values more than anything else
she wants foot soldiers not free
thinkers on her team
so could he find himself back on her
team in the future after all peacemaker
killing someone is nothing new to the
suicide squad this is a team full of
murderous super villains peacemaker is
no saint but neither are any of the
criminals involved in task force x
waller might still see a purpose for him
so it's possible that she might call him
up to the main team once again somewhere
down the line
it's cow or never the season one finale
of peacemaker features unexpected and
epic cameos from the justice league
while wonder woman and superman are out
of focus and shown through the use of
silhouettes jason momoa's aquaman and
ezra miller's flash actually have lines
and show their faces however there's one
crucial member missing from the lineup
here batman the dark knight's existence
was already confirmed in the series so
where is he hiding during this scene did
the batmobile break down or something
again this could give credence to the
theory that peacemaker takes place after
the flash film considering the movie is
said to be batfleck's swan song in the
dc eu there's a good chance that the
justice league might be a member short
for a while
no one expected adebayo to go in front
of the world and confirm the existence
of task force x and what it does perhaps
even more shockingly she exposes her
mother's identity and role in this
program
it's an event that's likely to have
major repercussions and could result in
waller being removed as the puppet
master of the suicide squad yet despite
adebayo's revelations there's no chance
that task force x will be shut down
it'll simply pop up under another guy's
this might present an opportunity for
someone new to take the reins of task
force x and the suicide squad adebayo is
an improbable candidate since she
exposed the whole operation but emilia
harcourt could be in line for a major
promotion her near-fatal injuries in the
season finale may move her out of the
field and into an internal role perhaps
a season two of peacemaker could address
who takes over the vacancy at task force
x
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]